Who you gonna call?
[laughs]
Hi.
I'm Ray Parker, Jr.,
writer and performer
of the Academy Award-nominated
hit single Ghostbusters
from the major motion picture
Ghostbusters.
But that's just one song.
I've written so many other
major motion picture theme songs
and submitted 'em
throughout the years.
Now they're available
and together
for one specially priced
compilation.
Songs like...
♪ You tried
to play the game ♪
♪ But it's driving you
insane ♪
♪ Jumanji ♪
♪ Danger in the jungle ♪
♪ There's a lion in my house ♪
♪ Come on, Mr. Computer ♪
♪ Throw me a bone ♪
♪ I said, Lawnmower Man ♪
♪ Get up off of my lawn ♪
♪ When Armageddon is near ♪
♪ You better get out of here ♪
♪ Looking like a deep impact ♪
♪ I ain't afraid
of no 'stroid ♪
♪ Watch out behind you ♪
♪ That's where I'm gonna
find you ♪
♪ Pelican brief ♪
♪ It's getting legal, y'all ♪
These songs have only been heard
by the highest level
of industry decision makers,
but now you can feel
like a Hollywood executive
in your own home.
♪ I'll see your face-off ♪
♪ Black guy walking around ♪
♪ It's a face-off ♪
[chuckles]
♪ That ain't even your face ♪
♪ Passion of the Christ ♪
♪ Get me down off
of this cross ♪
♪ Passion of the Christ ♪
♪ You know,
my daddy is the boss ♪
♪ Disturbia ♪
♪ That's not even a word ♪
♪ Gonna unnerve ya ♪
♪ ♪
♪ Now, there's a whole lot
of kinky ♪
♪ Bet that room is stinky ♪
♪ Fifty shades of Grey ♪
[chuckles]
All right, white people.
♪ Who's a slave? ♪
♪ I'm not a slave ♪
♪ Uh-oh ♪
♪ Twelve years a slave ♪
Whoops!
[imitates whip crack]
There's one thing I know.
It's that persistence
makes perfection.
Ha ha.
Sure, Hollywood missed out,
but that doesn't mean
you have to.
♪ Down in the basement ♪
♪ What's going on? ♪
♪ It's a apt pupil ♪
♪ There's a kid
and a Nazi down there ♪
♪ ♪
(male announcer)
Order now to receive
your free copy of
Bobby Sings the Twos:
theme songs to sequels
that were never made.